i know what it's like to shoot without
an intimacy director
the messy embarrassing feeling for the
crew the internal devastation for the
acto
in the wake of the allegations against
noel clark it was no surprise michaela
cole
that's never up for discussion why am i
here
because i'm fixated on the past the
creator and star of i may destroy you
the hit series about consent who won
both best actress and best miniseries
alluded to abuse when picking up her
award
calling on the industry to make
productions safer and thanking her own
intimacy coordinator for doing just that
thank you for your existence in our
industry for making
the space safe for creating physical
emotional
and professional boundaries so that we
can make work
about exploitation loss of respect about
abuse of power
without being exploited or abused in the
process
the audience was half empty and masks
but in the year of lockdown
the shows being celebrated attracted
record viewing figures
let's cut to the public as the program
makers want them
mute and captive
bafta's virtual audience announcing the
only award voted for by the public
can you announce can you see that right
after the new
britain's got tally diversity's black
lives matter inspired dance routine on
britain's got talent
which prompted more than 30 000
complaints
took the prize this as much as there is
so many conversations and so much that
needs to change
this is what change looks like and
following unprecedented change by bafta
to improve diversity
originality and risk-taking was rewarded
thank you so much sky arts for being so
brave and so
pioneering putting on british tv the
first spoken word poetry show
sky news took vast news coverage
couldn't produce a program like
inside idlib without a huge group of
talented dedicated
passionate journalists and we had those
in bucket loads
and along with the greatest tv moments
of the year there was a nod to the
realities of working from home
and a celebration of when things go
wrong as well as right
yes yes you can have two biscuits lucy
gotta
sky news